we start this news hour with breaking
news at least 12 people have been shot
dead in Thailand police say a soldier
went on a shooting spree in the City of
korad Swain he joins us now on the phone
from the Thai capital Bangkok Wayne do
you spring us up to speed what more can
you tell us yes they're still very much
an ongoing and developing situation as
you rightly said in the City of korad
otherwise known as knock-on ratchasima
this is a city about 250 kilometres to
the northeast of the capital Bangkok
according to report some of the police
are now beginning to confirm as well in
Alger within the last two hours or so
began shooting on a military base in the
city near the city and killed a
commanding officer and at least two
others on the military base then stole a
military vehicle and drove toward some
center of nakhon ratchasima shooting at
people as we went out towards a shopping
mall called terminal 21 the shooting
that had continued inside the shopping
mall there is video circulating on
social media and clearly they're very
loud gunshots multiple gunshots coming
from within the shopping mall itself it
is believed that he has hostages inside
that building as well he's also been
streaming the shooting on social media
on Facebook posting regular updates up
until about 40 minutes ago his Facebook
page has now been taken down one of his
last posts suggested where he said in
his post that he's tired now he said I
can't move my finger anymore his photo
has clearly been posted on many social
media sites as well so the police have
the entire area and a lockdown they have
been joined by the military as well some
police commandos are being flown also
from the capital Bangkok so still a very
much developing situation and when the
images that we're seeing from the scene
right now it looks like we're looking at
images that are coming from inside the
mall we've also seen some images from
outside the mall this looks like it's a
very busy area a lot of people there yes
certainly
Nakano steamer is a busy city was very
much known as the Gateway to the
Northeast again pretty close to the
capital Bangkok it is a bustling High
City and the shopping mall as is the
case in many areas of Thailand would be
the center of the action on a Saturday
evening and around 7 o'clock so about an
hour ago when this was all beginning to
filter through on social media and in
the Thai media would have been very busy
in that area
as I say the police and military very
much had a cordon in place now locking
the area down there is been a statement
made by a police spokesperson advising
people who are in the area to move right
away those who live in the area to stay
indoors and listen to instructions from
the security officers so still very much
an unfolding situation as I say and I
mentioned that the social media posts
that he has been posting one of the
things that he said again about an hour
ago on Facebook was should I surrender
so it seems perhaps that the situation
may come to an end soon or at least of
course that is the hope but again this
situation still changing as we speak
Wayne how unusual is it to have a mass
shooting in Thailand mass shootings are
very rare here you know gun crime is
relatively common access to guns as well
so easy there are strict laws
surrounding gun ownership in Thailand
but it is very easy with corruption
being so rife here with the black market
being so strong it is relatively easy to
get your hands on on this and on guns
this man is again we should point out is
believed to be a soldier a serving
soldier and the Thai Army we began the
shooting spree on an army base so
clearly access to weapons there easier
than you'd be for a civilian member of
the public but generally mass shootings
in Thailand are very rare they do not
happen very often but again gun crime is
common which
also point out that the military in
Thailand played a major role in life
here the military is often involved in
politics it is involved in business and
Thailand and some would say that it is
the most powerful organization in this
country and one again one of the posts
that he has made on social media refers
again we don't know the motives for the
shooting we don't know much about the
soldier himself but one of the things
you did point out on social media was
making a reference to corruption again
too early to say whether the main
motivation for the shooting about
corruption as a major problem within the
military many allegations of them being
involved in illegal business illegal
trade and so they do play a very large
part in Thai society details which I'm
sure will come out in the hours and days
from now for now thank you for that
that's Wayne hey just recapping there at
least 12 people have been shot dead in
Thailand the active shooter is
apparently a soldier he went on a
shooting spree in the city of Corot and
it is believed that there are now
hostages being held inside that mall and
we will bring you more as it comes to
hand